[Music]
and not interested in news submitted by
a big bass Billy BBB the BBBS a new
study claims that women get bored of
having sex with their partners after
only one year Oh for real I can see that
is that women or also men no men might
be like three months yeah good one you
know I've gotten longer than that
without getting bored of it I think it
said it's just a general it's a general
like average yeah just kind of spice it
up dude you gotta come in pretend to rob
the house beat her up taper up and
they're like it's me exciting for you
just kidding you didn't get raped one
year I won't play these games new study
from South Hampton University where they
why are they studying this [ __ ] they
should have studied Americans
yeah we're South Hampton is that decided
America that New York okay so for this
study they research 11500 that's a lot
people that's a good pool that's a big
pool that's a proper ladies how do we
become involved I've never been part of
a survey just to sign up for oh yeah
yeah I did surveys when I was in college
yeah so there'll be a student it's just
easier but that's how yeah but then
they'll put it up on like Craigslist or
a different size yeah yeah so the
results of this study revealed that 34%
of women said that they totally lost
interest having sex with their partners
after one year where only 15% of men
said they felt the same say oh [ __ ] is
it because men feel like that number
should be even less time I feel like
using isn't it more so because women
just are so more emotional so maybe the
guys start getting on her [ __ ] nerves
yeah
yeah that's when the honeymoon phase
yeah he's feed so then that's why I'm
like oh I'm gonna hate this [ __ ]
ah and then the guys are more like I
just I could fall the couch and I prefer
the less honeymoon phase I actually like
the relationship now better than I did
when we started yeah because it's too
volatile lazy no because in the
beginning it's too volatile and there's
no realism new now there's like a point
where she and I can lay down talk to
each other and the friends we're friends
walking back give me an illusion do the
honeymoon phase
that's when you feel the most everything
is crazy and new just being in a room
with them feels amazing or like let me
say let me go to [ __ ] McDonald's girl
and then you feel like you're at a
five-star restaurant and you're just
like I'm gonna get some [ __ ] later I
feel that way right now still though but
it's in a different way though it's not
like Oh everything is more like I could
be next to this person for the next
seven hours and I can enjoy every moment
yeah feeling better because if I had the
option to go back in time and date the
KC from the honeymoon phase and go
through all that again honeymoon phase
is coffee and then when you pass that
it's tea that's what it is yeah it's
like it's like it's a slow burn you know
it is slow it's a nice comfortable yeah
cuz usually less oh it depends on the
girl okay yeah I mean sometimes I don't
even get a honeymoon phase it's just a
lust phase and then I go bye-bye it was
kind of cool cuz I had this is the
polite way of saying are you waving from
your window bye-bye no I had a moment
last week where uh like we were just
kind of chilling and then we just
watched this [ __ ] uh this dude in
South America swim with the crocodile it
was like his best friend and [ __ ] oh
yeah and we were watching it for an hour
and then still we were just talking
about crocodiles you're here crocodiles
tries [ __ ] let me put lotion on it so we
just kind of laid in the living room and
this shiipa lotion on my face and [ __ ]
and that's like hey this is kind of nice
like I like this that was one of my
favorite moments in our relationship in
the past three years doing nothing
you bring that up and during your vows
for the wedding man you know maker
[ __ ] yesterday well we were doing
nothing and then you were just putting
the face on the lotion on my dry ass
face probably one of my favorite movies
you didn't do that during the honeymoon
I mean phase either we were too busy
like trying to go out do all this like
other stuff and make sure that the other
person is feeling the the highest point
of excitement it's the expectations in
the honeymoon phase that feels different
because when it's like you're putting up
a front doing that and another one
that's look after everything simmer down
and now it's two real people doing that
yeah and it's like those type of moments
to the dice feel like in the beginning
of the relationship you could probably
experience that with some other girl to
that moment that that's true I can't
experience it with any other that's
profound dude you should say that to all
the girls like we're not romantic
anymore you're like but baby I can do
that with any other girl like right now
like this is just stuff I can only do
with you I'd be like oh [ __ ] right I
hope someone watches this and looks over
at the significant other be like you
never put lotion on my face compare
their relationships oh my god it felt
like a heart hug you know what I mean
like
it's a hard hug that was like one of
those feelings that it was a new feeling
for me and I said oh sure I could
probably marry this a hug for the inside
now like me and TIFF we uh we we were
reading this one article and it's you
guys are both holding it together like
this no you're reading it was it was an
article about by old people who have who
their significant other has already
passed on and and and they were just
being interviewed about what they
remember the most and this like let me
cry during this job and he was saying
how the most memorable moments are the
moments where like he was saying like
there's just one night where the power
went out it was their hunt it wasn't
their wedding night their wedding night
the power went out and then for some
reason they know he forgot it
you tell it that okay yeah the wedding
night in this husband because his wife
passed away she he was just saying how
like his most favorite most memorable
moment in their entire relationship
because they were married for like
decades was on their wedding night where
they had two separate beds but they
pushed them together so I could sleep
together but then they went in the
middle and the bed split apart and they
didn't follow laughing at it and like
the way he told it though like you could
see it cuz he started crying
and I saw story like that the little old
man's like one of my favorite moments is
every night before bed she asks me if I
want water and she brings me a little
bit of ice cream Oh cute yeah and he's
like the moment like that stir my heart
and I was just like you look back at the
best party relationship I seldom hear
people say more the first time we ever
fought it's not one of those like one of
those big news ago the first time we
went to Paris
yeah it's not the big small thing it's a
small like you guys look like [ __ ]
you're hanging out in the living room
and I remember maybe it was it was a
month ago or two we had a fart war
here's [ __ ] laughing dude and then
for some reason the funny but I learned
she could control her [ __ ] farts yeah
I don't know where we started no I'll
come at ya I'll come and I'll let you
know if she can pinch it and why pay
attention make sounds always you know we
were we were I don't know yeah I don't
know how we got to this but I started
representing Little Tokyo like I was
like I was like hey where are we from
Little Tokyo been charting gang war yes
so then so then she goes say that again
but Little Tokyo yeah but say how you
said before and I was like all right
Little Tokyo [ __ ] and she goes and I'm
like what the [ __ ] did you just do she
goes do it again do it again yeah Little
Tokyo [ __ ] and then she just went
[Laughter]
and I was like this this is a talent I
felt like yeah I never knew this about
you and he stops me because I love you
[Laughter]
so hard it was I think that's what it is
to maybe I have like a you know a really
successful relationship like you you
kind of like remember those things and
then you realize that that happiness is
more important than everything else so
you kind of move on from all those
things and I always think about that -
what about you - I don't what about you
to make me cry out what's your moment
our favorite moment yeah like a random
thing everything kind of just morphed
like crazy right now as soon as Tyco was
born like that like our level hit like
this new level let me start right now
I'll hit everything should hit this new
level before Tiger like what was one of
your favorite late like Bart for it in
the pillow a big crop doesn't mean that
I think his party to something that's
crazy now he can fart in the rumors mean
I'm okay why I don't know it's the level
I don't know Mom hormone like you mean
you could tolerate that toxic [ __ ] you
doesn't have to leave anymore like I
don't get pissed so you're okay with
that you're like you gave me a baby
you can fart okay I think me being a dad
like help me redeem myself
[Laughter]
or maybe I'm just really sleep-deprived
like it's also hard for her to get mad
at me now it was like a lot of it's like
I'm telling you it just you're taller
it's just like higher now yeah like for
him yeah so god we just don't need gas
masks we just need baby baby no are they
having that baby or like having like
that extra person where you need a team
up it I think pets is like the first
step towards it yeah but it's like it
puts the couple on in a team yeah it's
like without a baby without the pet
without having that common like I don't
want to say project but you know in
responsibilities yeah it's like you you
you have like this I'm the guy you're
the girl the relationship now you're on
opposite ends office yeah your wants
they have their why now it's like an
enemy yeah but then once you have it
yeah common enemy now yeah I pad
whatever he finds I guess the [ __ ]
truth what the [ __ ] you a not [ __ ] you
set now [ __ ] sir
hey what up all my positive people I
want to hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave little comments below for
the last video over here
[Music]